direction la catalogne ou le tribunal
supérieur de justice a rejeté la demande
du gouvernement catalan de prolonger le
couvre feu dans une centaine de communes
seules 19 villes de la région seront
encore concernés par cette restriction
les précisions de lessing là à barcelone
dès ce vendredi minuit le couvre feu
prend fin à barcelone il était en
vigueur depuis le 16 juillet dans une
centaine de communes de la catalogne
cependant le couvre feu n'est pas levée
sur l'ensemble du territoire catalan le
tribunal supérieur de justice catalan a
décidé de l'appliquer dans seulement dix
neuf villes de la région toujours de 1h
à 6 heures du matin et barcelone en est
exclu malgré la demande du gouvernement
catalan quelques jours plus tôt la
région souhaitait prolonger le couvre
feu d'une semaine supplémentaire dans
148 villes ayant un taux d'incidence de
125 cas pour 100000 habitants mais le
tribunal a rejeté cette demande et
applique le couvre-feu dans les villes
ayant un taux supérieur à 254 pour
100000 habitants à la suite de cette
annonce la mairie de barcelone annoncé
qu'elle allait renforcer les contrôles
policiers de 2h à 6h du matin notamment
dans les zones très fréquentées comme
sur les plages pour l'instant les bars
et restaurants doivent fermer leurs
portes à minuit trente les représentants
du secteur demandent une ouverture
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin il indique que
ça limiterait les rassemblements sur la
voie publique et les fait illégale des
phénomènes incontrôlable qui ne génère
pas d'emplois ni d'impôt selon les mots
du principal syndicat de restaurateurs
interdiction de se réunir à plus de 10
personnes a elle été maintenue sur
l'ensemble du territoire de la catalogne